[Music]
hallo YouTube just love us and my
friends this is Gungan here
welcome to the 48th episode of dirty
chest tricks
anybody who wants to learn the Sicilian
the first thing he needs to know what he
is going to do against mora gambit due
to its aggressive piece layout fixed
structure in less theory at club level
this opening is one of the most popular
choice against sicilian specially below
2000 now the set of which I'm going to
advocate here not only contains a lot of
tricks but as we will see that if white
routinely turn out normal Mora gambit
moves then black can literally win the
games very quickly in this line there
are very few games available in database
and that's why it's a great surprise
weapon for you in tournament practice
the opening arises after the following
model E for C Phi D for C captors D for
and now white offers the second pawn
with the moose c3 here my recognition is
you should certainly capture this pawn
and after Knight capture c3 you can
already see in return white get to open
files for his species and a great attack
but no matter we are going to continue
with one of the main line of Mora gambit
starting with Knight to c6 Knight to f3
d6 Bishop to c4 and now a very important
move a six a six is controlling the
vital square B Phi and we are all set to
play now Knight to f6 it is very
important to understand that without a
six if you play the move Knight to f6
then straightaway you enter
- one of the more a gambit trap and here
after the movie fie just within the 7mu
of the game black position is completely
bustard if you want to know more about
this line then I have covered in detail
in my dirty chess tricks against
Sicilian episode number 9 so kindly
check it out
okay so a six white will castle on the
Kings side we are going to play Knight
to have six and now the normal move of
the Mora gambit is to play Queen to e2
rook to d1 and start utilizing this open
C and D file and I think this is one of
the most popular choice by void as below
mm not many players think about the
opening in very deft as a Mora gambit
clear if you are white in this position
then my recommendation is you should
certainly play the move h3 and avoid the
move Bishop to g4 which we are about to
see before we look at Queen to e2 the
important point I like to mention here
that if I add this position doesn't work
because we have the control on the b phi
square and here the simple line can goes
like this d captures e5 Queen captures
d8 Knight captures d8 Knight captures e5
attacking on f7 but after the star move
Bishop to e6 not only black has
consolidated his extra pawn but white
has hardly any more threats in this
position so let's see most popular
choice by White Queen to e2 well after
that my recommendation is you play the
move Bishop to g4 pinning down the 9 and
as you have seen I have highlighted by
the arrows the simple but very effective
plan of the campaign by black that is he
wants to play a six Bishop to e7 castle
on the King side remain a solid pawn up
and asking white where is your
compensation lies
the main line continues with rook to d1
so pinning down the d6 pawn and thus
threatening the movie Phi which right
now not possible because our c6 Knight
is covering the white alley Phi square
so black should continue with his
routine Penang ethics and we reach to
the most critical position of this line
when I check this position in online
database I found out that here there are
two popular choice by the white and
those are Bishop to f4 and the MU H
three and myself as a Sicilian player I
have seen this moves in my games 90% of
the time
well amazingly enough let me tell you
this both the moves leads through the
great disaster in the white camp and
that we are about to see the first move
I want to consider is history which is
more natural in this position but here
after a few captures let's say Bishop
captures f3 Queen captures f3 Knight to
e5 attacking to sports Queen to e2 and
after night capture c4 Queen captures e4
and the move Bishop to e7 not only black
has exchanged two minor pieces which
reduced the attacking potential of white
but on the next turn black is going to
Castle and it is very unclear where
white is going to attack probably the
most critical response in this position
is ePHI taking the benefit of pinned d6
pawn but still after the forcing line
that is defy counter attacking the Queen
Queen to b3 and now the simple move
Knight to d7 and no matter however white
respond
he got miserable position so as the
knight is attacking on e5 white can
support it with either of the two mu but
none of them gives any satisfaction
result to the white camp
the first obvious move effort is a very
bad one the simple reason is after Queen
to b6 the Queen's are going to be
exchanged and black will be a clear pawn
up and instead of that if you operon
continues with Bishop to a4 then black
should castle first
so if white wants is pawn back this is
the right time he can go for it but
still after the following sequence that
is night to see Phi attacking the Queen
Queen to b4 night to d3 double discover
a check so wide response is force white
has to keep guard the bishop and the
only good move is Quinn to d4
but after Knight captures B to rook to
b1 and Knight to c4 there is no change
in the position as black is still a
healthy pawn up so h3 is a completely
harmless mu in this position and that is
why Bishop to f4 is one of the most
popular choice by white as it
pressurized the d6 Square and white
pieces are actively placed well yes
indeed that's true but there's one
problem that after this move black
instantly get a winning position and you
will be fascinated once I will show you
my tricky bet line how often fight
completely demolished within few news
after this situation here we are going
to continue with night 2 H Phi attacking
the bishop and Bishop has the only good
move Bishop to e3
if you operon continues with Bishop to
g3 then after the simple continuation
that is Knight captures g3 ash captures
j-3 Knight to e Phi is not a good mu in
this position so my recommendation is
you continue with H Phi taking good
advantage of that pain and after the
move Queen to e3 and the MU H for you
can already see the H file is going to
open up black major pieces will flood on
the edge file and even after a pawn up
it is only black who is the
in charge of the attacker I have
attached a model game in the PGN which
will give you a very good idea how to
generate attack from this position okay
Bishop to e3 what else and before I move
on I like to mention that even title
players has fallen into this tricks and
in many of my games
I simply crushed my opponent after the
following model that is Knight to e5
attacking two times Bishop to b3 now the
simple move Bishop captures f3 pawn
captures f3 and now Queen to h4 and
fight position is completely collapsing
so the simplest plan I want to follow is
Queen to h3 and Knight captures f3 and
nabbing the White Queen
that means White has to act very very
fast which in fact not there in this
position there are two mu stride in this
position and let's see each by turn the
first mu I want to consider is King to
g2 which has been played by a 2,000
rated opponent against an international
master so idea is very simple what is
stopping the move Queen to h3 and here
if you are feeling very aggressive then
you can go ahead and play the move GI
however I personally like the line which
black players choose in this game that
is Bishop to e7 a simple developing move
which gives black a great deal of
flexibility white continues with rook to
g1 black plays the obvious move Bishop
to g5 so once the dark square bishop
will be exchanged
then black attack will become more
potent and in the game why it continues
with Bishop captures G Phi Queen
captures G Phi if King to have fun then
Queen to h4 is a very strong reply so in
the game white continues with King to h1
black plays the forcing move Queen to f6
a
attacking one half three and the only
way to defend this pawn is to play
Bishop to d1 what an ugly move White has
to play after that black simply continue
with rook to c8 so planning his Knight
to c4 if it's required and white
continues with rook to be one which i
think is a great mistake because now
black instantly get a winning position
after Knight to f4 attacking the Queen
Queen to even and black player continue
with G fire which is perfectly fine in
this position but instead of that black
get the instant win if he had played
this move Knight to d3 Queen to d2 and
now the star mu in this position looked
to see Phi and this rook lift is a very
deadly and a very cunning reply for
example the normal looking more in this
position is Bishop to c2 attacking on
the night but here comes the cute point
behind this rook live black will
continue with a look to h5 anyways if
white plays rook to g2 the Knight
captures g2 and apart from it any other
moves let's say Bishop captures d3 then
there comes boom hahahaha yes indeed
it's a checkmate scenario for the white
camp the second more I want to consider
is Bishop to a4 check which has a very
nice idea that if black foolishly played
the movie file then white can sacrifice
a piece there and get some attack on the
black king well here the simplest move
in the world is you continue with King
twee 7 even though it looks ugly your
king is quite safe on e7 and if it's
required then can transfer to the AB 6
square this position has been reached
one time between a 2300 plus rated
opponent against a GM where I think
white become desperate and Khan
Navid rook captures d6 well the GM
replied very calmly he simply collect
this free rook and after the obvious
reply Queen d2 check of course you
cannot go to the e7 because of the
simple move Knight to defy tech and the
point is if you take this free night
then there comes Bishop to g5 and your
queen is a Connor but of course black is
not that much fool and here he continued
the accurate response King to c7 and the
game finished very quickly after the
following continuation that is Knight to
defy check King to be hit Queen to e5
which created the checkmate thread but
black defends elegantly with he captures
defy and I think this is a winning move
because after the sequence that is Queen
captures defy Knight to f3 check King to
have fun and the Moon Knight to f4 black
has a multiple thread and if white give
up the dark square Bishop then there is
no attack in this position as black is a
clear two-piece up instead of rook
captures b6 the more solid reply is King
to g2
which in fact happened in one of my game
against a feed a master where I continue
with g5 and I think this game is a model
demonstration how good black chances are
in this position ok my opponent
continues with Queen to d2
so he's attacking two spots and in fact
I have the only reply King to f6 which
save both the spot
my opponent continues aggression with
rook to Jeevan I played Knight to f4
check and now by force white has to take
it otherwise Knight to f3 will happen so
he took I took back and after Knight to
e2 it looks like white is generating
some attack but after blacks
reply game is completely lost for the
white before I show it to you I like you
to pause this video and find out what is
the winning move here for the black well
I hope you find this wonderful blow BAM
a wonderful Queen sacrifice if Y take
then after Knight captures f3 not only
black will regain the Queen but at this
position he's a clearly three pawn up so
that's why in this game
my opponent continued with King to have
fun but this doesn't help as after the
move Queen check the only replies rook
to g2 after that I simply consolidated
my F pawn feet Bishop to at six so open
H and G file pressure is too much for
the white in the game my opponent
continues with night to Jeevan attacking
the Queen
I played Queen to h1 and here he played
Queen captures b6 which i think is a
decisive mystic of the game as after the
move rook to g8 my opponent simply
resigned as one can clearly see that
after rook takes rook takes king to e2
rook captures even rook captures even
and Queen captures even not only black
emerge with an extra piece but black has
an extra pawn on H file which is going
to be Queen very fast that's it guys I
hope you enjoy and learn this wonderful
tricky line against Remora gambit
remember that after the move Bishop to
e3 we have the forcing sequence start
with Knight to e5 Bishop to b3 Bishop
captures Queen captures and star mu
Queen to h4 and after this however white
plays he get completely lost position
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care